i'm joined by the former northern
ireland secretary of state lord hayne
peter hayne good to talk to you lord
hayne well you've had plenty of
dealings in your time there with the dup
i know
and and talk to us then about the
potential for the dup to go
for a hardliner and what that might mean
well it's a very serious moment in
northern ireland politics generally
and a shame for her for
arlene foster because she was the first
woman leader of unionism
in northern ireland she broke the glass
ceiling and
many people saw her as a very hopeful
figure
in the early stages but i think she lost
her way
and the dup lost its way and
the fact is that even her own
constituents to
whom you interviewed didn't really know
what she stood for
in the end but her biggest failure and
it wasn't just her
the dup hitched their wagon to boris
johnson's
brexit and that was always going to end
up
in a mess in northern ireland there was
either going to be a border
across the island of ireland with the
republic to the south or there was going
to be controls and checks
across the irish sea to the rest of the
united kingdom england scotland and
wales
and it's boris johnson wasn't honest
with her
and she was taken in by him he sold her
a pup
and i think that ultimately is why her
leadership
has ended she got taken in by him
and uh you know it's created a situation
in northern ireland of great unionist
unease
and loyalist unease in particular which
has been responsible for
the some of the unrest and the the
trouble that we saw on our
television screens over recent weeks
yeah but staying with the
the brexit theme you mentioned there
that the gullibility i suppose when it
came to taking
the prime minister's word about there
being no
border between the rest of the uk and
northern ireland but doesn't it go
further back than that
in the support for the theresa may
administration when the dup clearly had
the whip hand
and three times at least opposed theresa
may
on the backstop and if she stayed in
power the dup there wouldn't be an
election until a general election until
next year
the dup would still be in an incredibly
powerful position
they would have and they'd have had a
better deal from theresa may on northern
ireland from their point of view
than they got from boris johnson they
enthusiastically
jumped aboard boris johnson's bus and
its career off the road
for northern ireland so ultimately
that was a failure of her leadership but
it is a failure collectively of all
their mps
and assembly members and collectively of
the the the dep's leadership and it's
paid a price at the polls
i mean the dups uh managed to both
alienate people's to its right
the traditional parties picked up votes
at its expense
and to the center where the alliance
parties picked up former dup
voters so it doesn't really isn't really
clear what it stands for anymore
and ultimately and i remember talking to
senior dup
politicians many of whom were my friends
from my time as secretary of state for
northern ireland
and asking them what they really thought
was going to be the outcome
of brexit and particularly this hard
brexit that wasn't aligned with the rest
of the union the
the european union and they didn't have
a clue they never had an answer
to it and they ended up in in the
predicament where they've paid the price
and northern ireland's paid the price
and lord hey we're running out of time
but i want to put you a potential big
picture here
if the the dup tears itself apart and
already
electorally we are seeing that the rise
and rise of
of shin fein uh both sides of the border
there is a potential isn't there what
within
a couple of years time there could be a
sinn fein first minister in northern
ireland and uh i shouldn't faint t-shirt
or prime minister
in the republic of ireland well it's
very uncertain
times ahead there's no question about
that and brexit is the trigger for it
and the dup
hits themselves to a particularly hard
form of brexit but what we now need is
leadership from the prime minister
and the secretary of state for northern
ireland to really engage with local
politics
because the dup is clearly in a crisis
unionism
is in a situation of uncertainty and
insecurity
and that is not good for northern
ireland's future
and what you need from the unionists is
building bridges
as alien foster hinted that she wanted
to do at the beginning
and in a resignation statement building
bridges across the divide that you know
so well
dermot that has disfigured northern
ireland for so long
we thought with ian paisley and martin
mcguinness joining together and becoming
the chuckle brothers in 2007 that there
was a new
hope and you know they've governed
together with ups and downs and
suspensions but never that i stayed in
power together
ever since with the exception of that
three-year suspension
so it can be done but it requires not
sectarian leadership from the dup
but the dup working with everybody else
and other parties particularly shin fein
doing the same
or we could see the whole stormont fall
over again and a political crisis
across northern ireland developing
that's what i fear and i know when
you're talking about building bridges to
northern ireland you're not referring to
boris johnson's plans for a physical one
i want him to stop talking about bridges
i want him to get over there and talk to
the local parties
and be a proper prime minister like john
major and tony blair and gordon brown
were
okay lord hayne great talking to you
thank you very much indeed peter